oui nous traque non c'est dany kif
pourquoi elle
parce que c'est ça qu'elle a peur
ce n'est
aidez moi à dreux 2 3
vous allez emmené damian jussieu et moi
je vais m'occuper cette tourte swing
limo
et attends tu vas faire quoi on va
s'amuser un peu tous les deux fait la
fortune ici
[Musique]
gratuit ou quoi ce truc battus mais il a
raison ce truc est magique
oui moi aussi
attend il y en a
[Musique]
quelle est la dernière chose dont tu te
souviens
banny il nous est titulaire si tu as
survécu
c'est parce que tu n'es pas une jeune
fille ordinaire
tu n'es plus seul plus maintenant
savez-vous ce gain de temps l'un d'eux
vous souhaite raconter sa première fois
j'avais 13 ans je maîtrisais plus rien
j'en sais rien j'ai paniqué il ya eu des
blessés
c'est ma copine tous les produits fils
il y as marre j'ai tué 18 personnes et
où par p
[Musique]
on n'est pas dans un hôpital on est en
cash
j'ai des quelque chose
un truc qu'elle voulait pas que je vois
je crois pas qu'on soit la peau quérir
cet endroit fait ressurgir des plus
grandes peurs il te les faire vivre
jusqu'à ce qu'elle te tue on peut s'en
sortir
ensemble
[Musique]